[Music]
athletes should not drink cow's milk
dairy is not a health food my name is
rich Rolle and I'm an ultra endurance
triathlete I'm a top finisher at the
ultraman World Championships which is a
double Ironman distance triathlon and
I'm also the first of two people to
complete epic five which is five Iron
Man's on five wine islands in under a
week my biggest challenges as an athlete
was trying to balance my life as a
father and as a husband and as a
professional lawyer at the time because
I didn't begin competing in my specialty
until I was in my mid-40s so 11 years
ago I was 50 pounds overweight I was
depressed I was unenthusiastic about my
life essentially a classic couch potato
sliding into middle-age and I had a
health scare and that health scare
motivated me to really take stock in
inventory of not just how I was living
but how I was eating I made the decision
to initially go vegetarian and then
ultimately deciding to remove all dairy
products from my diet and I have to say
that removing the dairy actually made
the most impact in terms of how I felt
there was an almost immediate resurgence
in energy and vitality that I would have
never expected in addition to just a
general elevated sense of energy and
vitality the biggest difference that I
noticed was an enhanced ability for my
body to expeditiously recover in between
workouts human beings are the only
species that drink the lactation of
another species and when you think about
that it doesn't really make sense there
are so many reasons to remove dairy
products from your diet it's not
environmentally sustainable or
responsible it's certainly unethical it
involves the mistreatment of millions if
not billions of animals and it's simply
not good for us right now we find
ourselves in the midst of an
unbelievable unprecedented health care
and environmental
the best way for you to avoid becoming a
statistic and doing what's right for the
planet and for future generations is to
ditch the dairy my name is rich Rolle
and I made the switch for good
[Music]